i do not need you telling me who to date
i didn't mean it like that you meant it
like
i saw you smiling at ritchie boyle
earlier and now i'm petrified that
you're running with a bad bat those men
may be customers but they are not
gentlemen could have fooled me in those
nice clothes you make for him if we only
allowed angels to be customers soon we'd
have no customers at all do we let all
of our customers keep black boxes in
back
it was you who was smiling at him i've
spent my entire life around animals like
richie boyle
you want to get them to back off you
look them dead in the eyes and you
pretend you're one of them you don't
need me worrying after you that's right
you can take care of yourself you're not
my
you know i do my father was
take that as a compliment
i will
i know
that you hope that i'll start loving
this the way that you do i do i do then
i'll train
learn the craft
one day maybe even take over the shop
but i don't want that i don't want your
life
you're entitled to your own i am you're
a smart young woman who's going to take
yourself far away from here i will
and when i go i just don't want you to
be all alone
[Music]
i don't need you
looking after me either
after all you're not my you know
fair enough
now if you want that raise first you
have to learn
what a bloody square
looks like
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
hey
what's this book do by the way i was
wondering what this was
i just said don't touch anything
he likes things the way that he likes
them
okay
he cares
about what he does
and that's why he's the best at it
it's like
somebody else i know
what is that you hey
what i said are you you're like are you
making fun no because i'm no joke i'm
not making fun
i'm not making fun
come
here baby what's wrong
did he do something
did he do something francis did he do
something again
francis he ain't family i know
he ain't even irish i know
he thinks we got it right
okay yeah somebody leaking olaf on
things
who
doesn't matter he's paranoid all right
and he's been telling my pops for months
my pops listens to
hey
francis
you know you're so smart
you can really learn a thing or two from
that kid you're the number two
your pops listen to you don't worry
about francis who cares about francis
you think i don't know what francis did
for my pops hmm
you think i haven't heard about it a
thousand
times
six marbles
yeah
but that's only because i wasn't there
because if i had been there that would
have been me then you you know that
right
francis thinks he can make more
[Music]
who's there
okay sorry
jeez
hey
look at this
you know what i like about you
what
you're going places
right i'm going blazing hmm
step two is drawing
and for some this can be the most purely
enjoyable step
[Music]
you're only just exploring
[Music]
but i will caution you to heed your
patterns
[Music]
they're there for a reason
this isn't art
this is a craft
we can talk about shocking originality
later
[Music]
the point now
is skill
[Music]
so
your patterns your proven forms
they aren't your enemies
they're the only friends you have
[Music]
[Music]
um
so
quiet dead quiet yeah back up back up
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on is anybody else here
you